von daher weiß ich auch gesehen hat was
fand ich auch ganz geil mit dir oder was
geht hier ist euer cani und freude gibt
es einen trick that won best of one zum
allerersten mal spiele ich das und ich
spüre dass nicht gegen einen brand im
spaß sondern hübsch was danach einen
doppelten rändern spar richtig gegen den
lieben peter und das ganze ist bisschen
tricky hier aber ich werde mich
hoffentlich schnell einfinden hast du
das schon öfters mal gespannt
vor allem auch berg weg gehen wir das
und ja genau und ja wir sind gerade auf
dem frischen berg webserver der herr
bergmann höchstpersönlich hat uns gerade
ein bisschen rum geführt ja ist wirklich
sehr schön
ja ich würde sagen wir gucken uns aber
an wenn du jetzt alleine schon ich weiß
wie man blogger unter so kauft ja gut
das ist ja ähnlich
ähnlich wie bei ready da habe ich gehört
gab es auch ein bisschen nichts ja
irgendwie läuft und sobald ihr penner
oder warum hab ich also auch nach hinten
gibt's das gold recht ich weiß nicht
hinten nach hinten ist definitiv auch
noch eine insel
was die zu bedeuten auch du jetzt gar
nicht gehört das mag aktie gibt es hier
ich habe null smaragde einfach wenn du
wenn du gegen wenn du jemand schlägt
hell wie oft tötet man sich denn wer
keine ahnung
christoph spies yamaha ich habe absolut
keine ahnung wie es zum allerersten mal
gespielt dass die ganze zeit so jetzt
reicht's aber okay
wo bist du bist wo bist du hast dich zu
mir gebaut wo bist du wirst ihn nicht zu
mir gesagt du bist du hast dich zu mir
gebaut
hallo
wenn ich mal angelegt aber du hast du
noch nicht in die mitte gebracht oder
nicht dass wir irgendwie so weil es ja
weiterhin relativ neue kann natürlich
noch bugs auftreten
aber du hast die mit weiteren solchen
flügen sein netz aber bisschen mit sagen
okay ich echt nicht mehr gebaut
warum siehst du hast dir nicht nötig
kaka der extra nach wie es frau dass sie
bloß über scheinen die falsche seite in
die falsche richtung gebaut
übrigens sollte was ich nicht sagen dann
aber der dumme später unterbricht die
ganze zeit
ich habe in meinen führerschein stand
ich bin sehr froh dass
soll jetzt mal ernsthaft alter wie viele
wie viele inseln gibt es hier ich dach
des wohnhauses von alter ist dass tricky
da gibt's einfach einen teleporter wo
bist du denn jetzt
ich bin überall und nirgends wurde ich
diesen teleporter benutzt habe ich kann
nicht sehen ich weiß allerdings auch
würde bist hast du schon mal in die
mitte gebaut oder nicht
ja ja ich hatte ich gesehen dass in die
mitte gewählt
oder ist das deine miete wurde battisti
gold insel weiß ich glaube dir etwas
einfach gedruckt revier für dich
dankeschön laster liegen
der mache ich dann höre ich da ich bis
dahin tschüss gefällt mir definitiv gut
auf jeden fall definitiv auf jeden fall
irgendwas fan und ich finde es auch im
etwas bot am meisten finde ich von den
games wobei sich finden manchmal ist es
ganz cool was anderes zu machen weil
sommer hat glaube ich letztens zu recht
angemerkt dass das gesehen dass noch aus
ag und links meer und wetter also ist
schon ist schon so also ich weiß in
erster zeit ist irgendwie ein bisschen
abgenommen so die kreativität oder die
diversität auf jeden fall aber ich finde
du hast ja auch nichts großartiges wir
so was spaß macht was ich cool finde
womit ich vielleicht auch bald mal
anfangen werde sind solche träsch games
wie das jetzt zum beispiel rewe
schumi oder luca oder so was machen die
mini games darauf habe ich eigentlich
auch bock dies natürlich dann wieder
mehr aufwand und sowas recherchearbeit
und sowas und von daher weiß ich auch
gesehen hat das fand ich auch ganz kalt
ist dann bist du da gerade hingekommen
also ich hab mich so erschrocken ja auch
schön für mich dass meine augen rund 203
ok ok perfekt und jemand anders ist
eingestellt oder bist du das willst du
wärst du da oben mit der gerade
ausgegangen ist na ja genau
ok dann war ich das tatsächlich ankommt
wieso heißt dann nicht plötzlich anders
ich heiße peterle tv nein du hast
schreiben aus dem chef ja du bist ja
elektronik du bist freddy phd das warst
du vorher auch nicht dann bin ich
schlafe oder ja
ja weil ich mich schlau bin märkte
strato im gegensatz zu dir wenig schlau
und nutzen einer umgebenden wasser den
führerschein bestanden ja richtig dazu
kein führerschein ist einfach so
glücklich das war ja auch ein witz aber
kein smartphone genau also was lernen
wir sozialen herr dreck server
neben mir gefällt das jetzt schon sehr
gut auf dem web und mir gefällst du auch
mal eindeutig sie durch lewis mit uns
heutzutage youtube ist nicht mehr das
was mal war nur noch spaß dies unterwegs
sind echte sparte brief in dem brief
gelegt also gehört von franck was ihr
vorgelesen hat ja aber wie kommst du
darauf einfach so fand ich ganz lustig
aber ein bisschen anmerken hier deswegen
ich dachte jetzt irgendwelche referenzen
zum spaß die es auf youtube gesagt dass
youtube sich verändert was ja auch
stimmt ja gut bist ja aber das ist ja
auch das aber das ist alles verändert
sich dann wenn man nicht mit der zeit
geht irgendwann stehen das ist leider so
finde ich auch nicht nicht nicht farfan
bringt man das ist ja alles hier markt
prinzip angebot nachfrage sonst was der
junge hat gelernt volkswirtschaft hat
aufgepasst
ja man mir einfach so worauf die leute
bockhahn das wird gemacht so was ankommt
wird gemacht und wenn es vielen leuten
gefällt dann wird's gemacht und alles
gemerkt so wie ich meine weiß wie ich
meine
okay der teleporter wurde aktiviert
peter jetzt einfach mal ein chat
geschaut dann ist auch bewusst dass das
es sowas gibt ja hab ich ja aber ich
wusste ja nicht wo das ding ist ich hab
gesagt dort importiert und hin erhöht
aber es ist eine coole variation bin ich
immer immer wenn das richtig lustig mit
dem teleporter nein spaß aber kannst mir
sagen wo das eisen ist eine anderen
seite na ja einfach an deiner eigenen
insel einfach so seitlich rechts oder
links ab da was ist auch gott ich dachte
hier sind schweine drin ist wenn eine
schweinefarm was für eine schweinefarm
die schweine erfahrung eine schweinefarm
im spielmodus man immer essen kann
okay machen die allen ja weiter von dem
sich meine schweine schwanger war nicht
in ordnung
mal schauen ob du nimmst diesmal
bezwingen kannst du bist und ihr alter
was geht nicht so einfach zwar nicht ich
werde hier auch bei wago tagen
wahrscheinlich weiter bitte hin
mein ziel ist es den ersten tag zu
überleben und danach ist egal als
regelverstoß dreimal das darf man aber
nicht regelverstoß dahin brauchen
wusstest du nicht oder das neue
verstoßen die man darf den kopf es geht
halt darum dass ich echt nur einen tag
also einen tag das ziel wenn ich den
überlebe ich weiß aber nicht wie es eure
taktik denn unsere taktik gewinnen
es heißt ihr gedeckt offensiv drauf oder
versucht ihr alles okay okay okay
der herr will schon daher schon ende
werde ich mir jetzt ein bettlaken weil
du nicht aufgepasst da sich da schon
jetzt gehe ich lieber besser ganz
schnell richtig getötet ja aber wie hast
du es geschafft alter ich habe einfach
ewig lang gezielt und dann plötzlich war
das wenn du gezielt das alter
ich habe einfach so ein long stadt
gemacht und da bin ich schon runter
gesprungen zum gold und dann hab ich
entscheide noch mal treffen
eigentlich werde jetzt im moment so zum
rumschreien und so aber ich habe es erst
spät gemerkt
sorry leute kennen das problem für alle
gefreut aber heute ist irgendwie so ganz
entspannt mit dem peter ist das immer
super romantischen ja sehr romantisch
mit mir was kann ich noch mit gold
tolles machen was kann ich locker zeigen
was kann man denn so noch kaufen
du hast du gar kein gold ich frag dich
ja auch ich weiß dass ich kein gold
abdullah hat die schnauze
okay noch nicht uns tage ich bei warum
widmen wo ich jetzt dass gold eine ganz
nach unten oder ok danke dass du sagst
müsste kann ich gar nicht sehen oh nein
die angst einfach weg du hast sie
weggeworfen habe ich nicht nein
da müsste sehr hier liegen oder hast du
gesehen dass die weggefallen
heruntergefallen wie du hast dir das
gold nicht gut in der mitte
ich hab dich doch gefragt wo das ist ja
in dem ich hier unten
ach mensch der alte bau spammer hier
schon wieder zu erhalten
also leute täter ist ein sehr harter
gegner immer wenn es ernst wird und dass
die bitte gekauft 20 was aber glück
gehabt gerade was geht um laras g kiel
ist mein bruder immer gesagt ja
kennst du den meinem bruder nein echt
nicht kannst du nicht sk dass sein
bruder ernst ja wirklich nicht ob du
kennst ja klar woher denn wie youtube
hast du immer ein ohr auf der straße
genau wie apeda durchsagen mal kurzen
prozess du lappen alte
ja leute peter s ii das war's dann von
heute die erkenntnisse sei kein spaß
peter als kritik für die ich so nicht
runter springen wenn der gegner kommt
ich habe angst vor seinem gesicht spaß
ist es okay was von heute mal ein
bisschen was anderes
ganz entspannt ganz entspannt und ganz
entspannt escape mein bruder tschüss
abonniert mich